des dysfonctionnements qui font courir
aux enfants gardés des risques pour leur
santé et leur sécurité voilà comment le
préfet d'indrloire justifie aujourd'hui
sa décision de fermer deux micro crèches
situées à tournord la bergerie et les
petits loups à l'origine une
sollicitation du conseil départemental
suite à des rapports alarmants des
services de la Protection Maternelle et
Infantile aucune amélioration n'a été
apportée précise encore le communiqué
malgré plusieurs injonctions le point à
avec Hélen
chapelet d'ici la mi-novembre les 22
enfants accueillis ici dans deux
structures de micro crèchees appelés les
Osio vont se retrouver sans solution de
garde la préfecture vient en effet de
décider de fermer définitivement les
deux structures pourtant reprises en
mars dernier par un nouveau gérant dans
un communiqué le préfet dénonce je cite
des 10fonctionnement qui font courir aux
enfants gardés des risques pour leur
santé et leur sécurité en inter
juste derrière cette porte c'est
l'incompréhension qui prédomine on sait
pas ce qu'on nous reproche parce que
nous dans notre quotidien avec les
enfants c'est pas du tout ce qui se
passe quoi les enfants on répond à leurs
besoins physiologiques on répond à leur
besoins affectifs on répond à tout quoi
ils ont à manger ils ont
des des choses qu'ils ont besoin quoi
les les jeux les activités moi je me
porte garant de de l'équipe du personnel
d'ailleurs euh le personnel est est
complètement atterré parce que ils se
sentent accusé de quelque chose qui est
complètement euh ubuesque pour nous euh
donc à part réfuter je peux rien faire
d'autre hein un papa dont la fille a été
accueillie un mois et demi dans une
crèche du même groupe ne semble pourtant
pas étonné de la décision préfectorale
on ouvend une méthode piicleur en fait
donc qui parle d'autonomiser les enfants
nous assez rapidement on s'est rendu
compte qu'on laissait pleurer les
enfants on retrouvait notre fille
souvent avec euh le les fesses rouges
donc moi j'ai vu j'ai vu les gants
étaient rêches et on s'est vite rendu
compte en fait qu'elle ne mangeait pas
assez on nous disait bah h cuillères
c'est bien bah on on s'est rendu compte
qu'en fait que le lait maternel qu'on
qu'on donnait à la crèche qui était
normalement gardé dans un dans un freeer
dans un congélateur B en fait il était
conservé dans un frigo qui ne
fonctionnait pas donc pendant le mois et
demi où ma fille était là-bas elle a été
malade à notre avis ça ça venait de là
dans cette structure le G nous assure
que les 10 employés sont qualifiés et
formés au secteur de la petite enfance
il compte évidemment contester cette
fermeture qui l'estime
injuste